turns out I'm an even bigger idiot then
I always thought I was I installed a
custom flat ride and I put it in the
wrong [ __ ] folder so I opened up my
roller coaster Caribe you like oh yes
let's make a let's play yes happy fun
times and it's like I open the game and
it's like open up in the flat ride and
the games like no s idea for SPD in
Alice so anyway I'm going to make some
paths over here so yeah see if this
covers up and actually fit in the middle
of this well no don't place it oh my god
this lag what the [ __ ] I can't even okay
at least is five tiles wide so that
means I can place it perfectly in the
middle
here yeah I'll just have to get rid of
those stupid overly paths
let's see exits no way you know if there
please thank you and and exits I
I [ __ ] up didn't I why you [ __ ]
kidding me
what are you doing thank you all right
invisible paths all the way beautiful
beautiful
wait no staircase no come on you can't
be serious can you staircase there you
go
it's hard to deal with these invisible
paths you know because they're invisible
all right that's kind of fixed okay I'll
see you about the rest later but first I
need to get the scenery done let's see
that's that's one awkward that's one
awkward sighs I'll probably need some
what is it two and a half two and a half
meters wide fences ice not even possible
you don't even have those how do I deal
with this you can get this mm-hmm
actually kind of do like like this I
mean it's a different colors than the
entrances but that's kind of a good
point in this case I guess um so I added
a little brown base to it and now I'm
going to add some plants in these pots
and then just see what else I can do I'm
going in topiaries oh well why not
they're always good get some foliage up
in here I don't want to have a big
concrete filled Park I don't have some
foliage here and there
let's see romantic now it just needs
more pillar stuff going on
let's see yeah this is not working too
shabby I think now where are those
diagonals dammit oh there you are
excellent now I just need some flowers
in there and some small staircases in
there and I think I'm all set
so just time-lapse
molded
well then that's that and there's my
little Plaza for the entrance and next
time I'm going to do everything else in
the bike I have no idea what I'm going
to do it to be honest but if you're like
making a big Main Street over here with
a ferris wheel at the end and just some
normal attractions on the sides here
maybe you could be an amp Coast was
something like that here but for now
that's just one thing left to do that is
I've got quite a few suggestions to get
rid of the cage turnstiles that's so
that's what I did
and how's that sad no I'm just going to
replace them with some smaller
turnstiles like yeah I've no idea let's
see mmm modern ones kind of suck
these ones are ugly but then again you
know what let's just go from modern ones
and we don't want to get sued so here's
the wheelchair entrance so that's that's
you I have no clue about it um let's see
maybe um not sure about these colors see
I should probably just keep them grey or
something like that
oops
yeah that's better I guess wait did it
just no never mind
so yeah that's that's so next episode
I'm going to do all kinds of other stuff
and so we see you then